here's a story from the post-millennial
breaking Nashville trans Shooters
Manifesto to be released by authorities
Metro Nashville Police Department Public
Information office told Fox 17 on
Thursday the investigation has advanced
the point that writings from the
Covenant shooter are now being reviewed
for public release that process is
underway and will take a little time so
I I think we're going to get it soon and
what we already know is that it does
relate to politics and what we've heard
from various news sources and even we've
had some people reach out saying that
they were either in the know or
something so it's all unconfirmed there
have another show saying they have
inside sources that suggest this
individual was anti-trump was was angry
over the the conservative politics and
the Banning on on transgender surgery
child sex change surgery and things like
that and they were trying to you know
maximize their that Carnage so I think
it'll be interesting to see and I'm
curious
how it manifests in the public because
when this happened within days the
Democrats turned it into a fundraiser
for themselves it is I I look at the
aftermath of the the way that the
Democratic party and and the politicians
surrounding the the the situation have
behaved it is atrocious and I thought
that I was not I thought that I got to a
point where I where I couldn't be
shocked anymore but I'm really surprised
at how the narrative has really really
been like oh it's about trans people
it's like a trans person actually killed
and targeted Christians children
children yeah and you have managed to
make the trans people the victims that
is absolutely astounding well above all
else you cannot be bigoted and you
should know better uh I don't I don't I
think the important distinction with
this individual because I wanna I'll
bring it back to gun rights is people
saw this shooter was trans therefore
they were talking about about banning
guns for Trans people and I'm like no no
this was a leftist gender ideologue yeah
that's a big difference I think it's
important that we we have a distinction
between someone who happens to be
transgender and someone who is in a
culture of a varying ideology yeah
because there are people who are trans
who are nowhere near that ideology and
we're friends and it's just like I don't
want that I don't want my friends rights
curtailed because this person's a
leftist wacko the left bism is the
problem or I bet my favorite way to put
it is when Tucker Carlson was accused of
being racist he was like what white
liberal women are the problem that's who
I'm complaining about because I have a
problem with black people so I'm like
exactly it's the ideology right it's
it's the cult yeah yeah outside
worldview right that's what it comes
down to and so even then even with the
world view people have a right to keep
in bear arms leftists have a right to
keep in bear arms and I'm I'm not gonna
but I will say we're getting to the
point where it's not gonna matter
whether you want them to or not if it's
active conflict if you have people who
are of leftist ideology like that dude
at the ice facility and I think it was
in Tacoma who fire bound to start
shooting at it or the guy who killed
Aaron Daniels at a certain point it's
like okay we need to stop violent
political extremists yeah and then and
what do you do so it's it's uh it
reminds me of that Carl popper I mean
the left likes to share if you tolerate
intolerance and tolerance wins and
that's how they justify Banning people's
speech and I'm like
I believe in the right to keeping bear
arms for everybody I believe in free
speech Free Press religion all that
stuff but then when War happens
all of this stuff is meaningless you
know yeah well then things are different
because then it's you've got supply
lines who's selling guns to who and so
the whichever sides over here will have
their own infrastructure or lack thereof
depending on their funding mechanism and
then the people over here will have
their thing and then it's very clear
right now it's there's not really battle
lines there kind of are and there's gun
stores these people walk in and they're
like do I sell this person or not and
they have the freedom to deny sales uh
the ATF actually likes it when gun
stores don't sell to people that might
be a threat but who are those people
this is actually a good idea for like a
video we could do have someone dress up
as antifa like wearing antifa clothes
and go into a gun shop and see what they
say yeah and you'd be like hey I wanna I
wanna buy guns I'll do it I wanna but
they might be like okay Phil
I love All That Remains actually you
know right the uh the green monster gun
shop in in Martinsburg they've been
recognized twice exactly you're like
walking hi I'm anti-fun like no you're
not filming watching the show get out of
here get out of here LeBron but I I
think you know I think the appropriate
response is if someone wearing antifa
Gear walk into a gun shop they should be
like let me know what you need
I I I don't think that is the
philosophical challenge right now should
a business be like no you are our
enemies you are dangerous and I will not
sell you this weapon because that's
actually a fair point uh correct if I'm
wrong but if if someone at a gun store
has suspicions that a person may use a
weapon for criminal ends they deny sale
but but isn't it a requirement did an
eye sale
um probably it technically probably is
it probably is like hey don't sell them
that gun you don't want to be the guy
Bob comes to you and says did you did
you think this guy was gonna say
something and then be like yeah I
totally thought he was gonna go shoot up
the mall and I sold it anyway yeah he
said something I did it I wanted the
money no I'm pretty sure they get in
trouble if they're like the guy came in
and he was talking about committing a
crime and I said well here's your weapon
like not sweating everywhere yeah
respectively an accessory to the crime
so then if someone comes in wearing
antifa gear you could I might be like oh
man no dude Well yeah if it's like let's
say let's go back to the peaceful times
in 2020 and someone walks in right then
when all that stuff goes going on in
let's say Oregon oh hands down uh I
think there would be a good case to be
like you know what I I'd rather not sell
to you no I'd go to someone else slam
dunk case you're not the kind of person
I want to assist I'll I'll stop there I
say if if I owned a gun store and it was
during the summer of love and someone
with antifa BLM gear came on I'd be like
get out right now one of my closest
questions one of my closest friends in
New Hampshire the gun shop that that
Highlander arms of buddy of mine owns
like if someone went in there and he
knew that they were leftist there is no
way yeah he would they he was gun Source
he'd kick him out himself like most gun
stores you think would do that not all
I'll take that back uh the ones with
backbones so maybe a little bit less
than half but like Dick's Sporting Goods
wouldn't right like they would be like
okay here you go have a good time yeah
but I feel like if a guy with like an
antifa bandana and like a shirt and
everything walked in there and it was
like it's time to go fight for justice
wear the gun like break this way sir and
they'd walk him over and be like here we
have a 12 gauge and it also yeah and it
also well it also depends is it a chain
you know a place where you don't have
control or is it a little mom-and-pop
gun shop where the owner is literally
there at the desk because there's a huge
difference between the service you're
going to get from both places like the
little gun store in my County no that
guy would totally deny sail but if it
were Dick's Sporting Goods no that
employee is just going to be like I
can't do anything I don't think it's a
corporation I can't I can't do it I
don't think he would he would even say
that he'd be like right this way sir yep
yep here we have a fine selection of
firearms for you exactly they would have
no idea gun sales at Dick's Sporting
Goods he'd be like buy an extra well and
and Dick's Sporting Goods got boycotted
they don't even sell guns anymore I
don't think yeah
okay I was gonna say they sell shotguns
and uh and like uh and I think they sell
like 10 22s and stuff like that yeah fud
guns yeah you go the 1022 is great
they're good those are great if you go
to the uh the dicks out here in I think
it's a Dick's in Maryland they have
basically just shotguns and I think they
might have some 22s and it's just it's
just it's it's pandering they they
pulled up the ARs like what was it six
years ago four years ago
um after a shooting and they were like
we're not gonna sell those weapons of
war we'll just sell shotguns and then
Walmart same thing Walmart pulled out
like Anyway six years ago and then they
finally removed all guns so let me let
me let me ask you a question if um if we
were talking about maximizing defense
minimizing collateral damage being safe
and secure which would you prefer you're
in your house you have I don't know
let's just say like what is it like a 72
caliber Sabo slug for deer
um and your 12 gauge or you have like an
AR-15 AR hands down 100 short barrel
suppressed and and and that's so illegal
right like suppressors it's like
restricted my point is just
Joe Biden says to fire the shotgun into
the air scare away yeah and they and
they and they're trying to sell people
like Buckshot for home defense for bird
shot or or bird shot but either way like
I kind of feel like
it would be fairly brutal to use a 12
gauge on somebody in your home so put
like a 10 inch hole in their chest oh
it'd be very violent this is correct
this is the problem with shotguns and
again this is like fud Knowledge from
the past shotguns are so much harder to
use well by an untrained person than
handing them an AR-15 I mean the AK-47
originally though was designed for the
average conscript to use very simple to
manipulate and and function a shotgun on
the other hand if it's a pump you got to
pump it every time you pull the trigger
which already mentally if you haven't
trained that most people aren't going to
Rack a second round that's just how it's
going to be an AR it's 30 round mag goes
in pull the charging handle safety and I
can pull the trigger 30 times and I'm
good to go super simple to use and The
Recoil and The Recoil when when we go
out to the range with people man they do
not they think the shotguns are the easy
ones yeah and I'm like we have the
shoulder pads for the shotgun if you
want to use them like why like now it's
like you might want to try using the
like the ar-556 or whatever because
that's about oh yeah you're not gonna
you might be like oh wow that was it but
that's the point point I guess the
argument being made by the gun control
people is
too easy to use yep smartphones are hard
they well and they don't even know
exactly what are the only argument they
really use is just in arguments because
it's inconsistent it's a weapon of War
it's what the military has and I'm doing
a video on it next week it's an M4A1 the
military has the same as a civilian
AR-15 well it actually turns out
civilian air 15s are better m4a1s the
military has a lot of them are shot out
they're crap AR-15s I can buy right now
for a thousand dollars are better than
what the military has yeah and the left
is not like that we uh I've got a KSG 25
oh you're familiar yeah yeah so for
those that aren't it's uh it can hold 25
shotgun shells and uh we're at the range
and it's loaded with Buckshot and the
wave of Devastation is is is Bonkers oh
yeah here's the crazy thing that's legal
in Maryland but an M1A is illegal that
is so funny an M1A is a is an assault
weapon yep and I'm like that's kind of
weird because for those if those don't
understand if you've got 25 shells
you've got 25 uh Charles buck shot I'm
watching this thing just melt melt the
the target the wood flying everywhere
it's being ripped apart like a chainsaw
is gutting it from every direction
it's kind of it it was kind of cool but
it was like also I think it's 225 lead
balls if you're shooting like nine shot
or something well placed
like well-placed shotgun shells will
remove parts of bodies like you will
literally take an arm off yeah if you're
if you're skilled with a shotgun it will
remove body parts large chunks very
Politically Incorrect very important but
this is a great that's a crazy thing to
me that that's the argument they always
go to is get a shotgun and I'm like
there's there's exotic rounds there's
weird stuff there's dragon's breath yeah
can you imagine a CCTV like video and
you just dragon's breath first it's
magnesium right I think yeah it's just
dragon's breath is like a shell loaded
with magnesium so it sprays flaming
metal at you I just awesome and that's
the stuff that they're like that's fine
yeah that's that's the stuff we're not
trying to keep but it's because they
don't understand exactly so sbrs the
perfect this is another perfect thing so
SBR short barrel rifles are technically
illegal unless you pay this little tax
stamp to the government
it's exactly a bribe I can own machine
guns because I paid 2 500 to the ATF and
other people can't it's the most
Preposterous thing ever but an SBR you
know a barrel below 16 inches is
technically illegal unless you do
paperwork to attack stamp pay 200 but
his last lethal than a 20-inch M16 which
will penetrate body armor with the right
ammo and a little 10.3556 can't so it's
it's they don't they don't know what
they're doing obviously with the
regulation they're old they're outdated
but a 20 inch M16 is way more lethal so
let me know this person what's going on
with this um this uh pistol brace band
they just did I saw there was a video of
members of Congress questioning the ATF
and the ATF couldn't answer basic
questions about they didn't want which
is typical that is a normal thing to see
when you're in when you see Congress
people interrogating people that are in
are in the regulatory body the ATF that
is charged with regular regulating
firearms and they know nothing thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time